there seems to be no end in sight to the
crisis at the southern border another
disturbing video shows a small child
being abandoned this time it's a
five-year-old boy
seen pleading with smugglers not to
leave him after being dumped just steps
from the texas border
[Music]
it's awful texas is responding to the
crisis by declaring
a disaster at our southern border
governor greg abbott says biden's
policies are emboldening
drug cartels and human traffickers but
the president doesn't seem to be
listening the white house just
officially ended
the remain in mexico policy that the
last
administration put in place
so jesse i'm asking a question perfectly
tailored for you
why do democrats hate migrant children
how long do we have greg
you know who shot that video the french
press
again that's foreigners doing the jobs
that americans won't do
i think there's more to the story than
we see here because they're saying oh
yeah
there's the little kid's gonna meet up
with their parents who already crossed
why wouldn't the parents just bring the
kid across
intact because biden's letting family
units come
and then he's getting them bus tickets
to tennessee that doesn't make sense
this i think was the french press
intercepting a child
sex trafficking drop-off that's not
that's my impression but good thing greg
that
kamala harris is going to address the
root causes she
um doesn't realize you can address root
causes and the crisis at the same time
so you get lung cancer you could wait
five years and get a class
action lawsuit together and sue big
tobacco
or you could stop smoking it and do
chemo
we could just do both at the same time
boden and harris don't understand you
can do both now she's going to go down
to guatemala
and she's going to address root causes
one of them she says is food insecurity
have you seen any of these migrants
crossing greg they do not look emaciated
to me
she also says the one of the drivers of
this migration is climate
i looked at the weather in guatemala
city it's 76 degrees you know what the
weather is in el paso texas
it's 82. it's hotter here than it is
down there
so they want to talk about root causes
the root cause is in the white house not
the northern triangle because when you
get rid of the remain in mexico
you get rid of the wall and you bring
back catch and release that's what
explodes the migration
i think honestly biden has anger issues
i think he's taking out his anger on the
red states
he's he's flooding texas with these
illegals these drugs
and these gang members he's cancelling
energy projects in oklahoma
and alaska he's boycotting georgia he's
shipping illegals to tennessee
i mean donald trump loved the blue
states
you know he was constantly rescuing
factories from michigan and
sending ventilators to new york and and
even save the dairy farmers with tariffs
in vermont vermont
a state that will never vote for donald
trump
so i mean joe biden can he lift a finger
for texas lift a finger joe you know
harold you just experienced your first
i would call that uh fruit bouquet you
know when you get a fruit
there's all these different parts that
jessie creates
and you don't know which one you're
supposed to attack first
that's that's his genius but i i i
overwhelming force overwhelming there's
like 16 things you could respond to
harold if you wish
look i i'd say i'd say a couple of
things um
she's going to go down and she's going
to address one part of it just
guatemala to guatemala right so the last
time there was a serious investment i'll
come and try to which part of the tree i
want to go
not go after but try to try to react a
little bit the last time we got
serious about trying to stabilize our
hemisphere in this regard it was under
president
kennedy he passed the alliance for
progress it was a very targeted relief
package
now drugs have been coming across the
border even when president trump was
there we had a serious challenge and i
wouldn't blame
president trump's border policy for that
democrats have to get serious more
serious about what happens with people
coming across the border and we have to
put more
people down there to protect our border
and if that means
uh having a debate about who's watching
kids and who's not watching kids perhaps
we should have that
compartmentalize that you think about
what we spend in the middle east to
stabilize there we spend billions a year
we spend
pennies on the dollar to stabilize our
own hemisphere
i don't want to keep having this
political argument and we can go back
and forth democrats gain a little bit
from it every two years republicans
sometimes
gain from it when i was in congress
george w bush was trying to advance some
sort of way to stabilize
down there and he talked about uh a an
immigration plan in fact the last
comprehensive immigration plan we had
you know put it forward
president reagan now you name me a ceo
of a company that could take
40 years to say we're going to revisit a
very controversial
serious problem we have within the
company and i'll show you a ceo who
doesn't work there any longer
we allow our presidents and our congress
year after year after year after year to
allow this silly conversation
not anything you said was silly but it's
silly that we have the conversation
repeatedly that it's a recurring one we
should be able to do both
address tobacco companies and address
the cancer to borrow i think that was
part of the treaty
we've got to figure out how we do that
you know
sandra to harold's point it does i think
this is a cynical take on my
uh from me which is a surprise when the
democrats are not in power
but not in power uh immigration is their
cudgel and then when the republicans are
not in power it's theirs
so it's a game in which every four years
the teams just switch sides
that's all they do they switch sides it
becomes an outrage for one side
and then the other side in and has to
has to defend themselves and this never
changes
and then watching the white house press
briefing today jen zaki's barely even
asked about this
hold this video of this five-year-old
boy up for the white house to respond to
i mean he's five years old carrying a
teddy bear his words don't leave me
where are you going no no no
don't leave the woman who left him there
to your point jessie
spoke to the associated foreign press
she says the parents are
already here the boys coming in from
mexico
a reminder that kamala harris and by the
way there's reports today
that she apparently panicked after joe
biden gave her this immigration
assignment might give us a clue why she
hasn't visited the border has it held a
press conference about this
there's a disaster declaration by the
texas governor about what's happening
there resources are running dry these
towns are seeing crime
on the rise and a little boy like that
why is that not being addressed and why
is the messaging
from this white house not changing when
saki was asked about this
in the press briefing room to her today
she said migrating to the border this is
our message puts you and others at risk
there is no message that they're putting
out there that our borders are closed
and there's a right way to enter the
country
why why does kamala harris not attack
the situation
and why is her own party not holding her
up to the responsibility
she's learning to hide it worked for joe
right so she's just out of that she's
just out of sight out of mind
deagon i have a theory would you like to
hear it of course all right
i think that the many defenders of the
status quo are guilty of distance
privilege
they're far enough away from the problem
not for it not to matter
so you have this declarations of
disaster those are the people
like that and then everybody else that's
not a big deal it's not a big deal it's
because you're not there
we can actually in new york city we can
reap the benefits of the cheap labor at
our restaurants
because but we never have to deal with
the problems down there well
the chattering classes in the elite here
in new york
and in los angeles washington dc they
look at texas and go
those you know stupid redneck groups
they don't really
care what happens um in red states to
jesse's point
i just want to know how many screaming
kids is it going to take for biden co
to give a damn amen because all they're
concerned about
is the words and the messaging right
just a few months ago we were arguing
over oh it's not a crisis or chaos it's
a challenge
well they can't wordsmith crying
children they can't massage the message
of a five-year-old
screaming to make it palatable to
the compliant media or their base what
binding company
have done is they broke intentionally
something that was fixed
to bring in people across the border who
are potentially
future voters and at the same time
they've simultaneously created
an opportunity for people for human
traffickers and drug traffickers
to profit off of human suffering and
tragedy
so if you look at the children being
terrorized at the border
but this is in biden's world this is
just
the political price to pay for their
policy
this is just collateral damage the
person who dumped that kid or the people
who dumped that kid at the border
they don't care about his well-being
just like the people in the white house
yeah but that
and that child still will always have
connections to whoever they hired
and that's going to be used against that
kid when he's in the united states
whenever they want
anything because they know the kid has
relatives there they need him to work
for do some work
some work for you know drug work
whatever he's got to do or else
somebody's going to get hurt
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else